some documents have been turned over to
federal investigators and they revealed
two previously undisclosed contacts
between Donald Trump's organization and
Russia during the 2016 campaign Donald
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
who for months denied any and all
involvement period with anything Russia
related which was ultimately proven to
be a lie exchanged emails with a
business associate weeks before the
Republican National Convention about the
lawyer possibly traveling to an economic
conference in Russia that would be
attended by top Russian financial and
government leaders including none other
than President Vladimir Putin according
to people familiar with the
correspondence there was a second
incident that we now know involved the
same lawyer Michael Cohen Michael Cohen
received a proposal in 2015 for a real
estate project in Moscow from a company
founded by a billionaire who once served
in the upper house of the Russian
parliament so we now know of not one but
of two specific real estate proposals
for Trump branded Moscow buildings that
were discussed during the 2016 campaign
and both involved Donald Trump's
personal attorney Michael Cohen if
you've ever seen this guy interviewed
you would already be aware of how slimy
the guy is but the issue for me isn't
whether these real estate deals were
done I mean they weren't we have no
indication that they ultimately were
it's that this type of contact has been
denied time and time again by everyone
associated with Trump between July of
2016 and February of 2017 alone that's
just an eight month period there were
almost two dozen prominent denials of
any contact with Russia by Trump
associates and the most interesting part
every time I say it there's someone in
our audience who gets mad you probably
have your finger hovering over the
dislike button right now if you're
watching on YouTube and by all means
press the button if it makes you feel
good this is sounding a lot like what
Christopher Steele said was happening in
that Russia blackmail dossier the
blackmail dossier says that in June of
20
sixteen Michael Cohen was involved in
emails involving Felix Sater the
russian-born
real estate developer and Trump former
Trump business associate about buildings
and Trump Tower Moscow and all of this
stuff I won't read it all to you again
but it's more and more confirmation of
what Christopher Steele had in that
dossier and if you're waiting around for
the trumpets to sort of come to terms
with what has happened I advise you not
to hold your breath because they would
sooner sing the Russian national anthem
while standing not while on bended knee
then admit that the Donald Trump
campaign did some really sketchy stuff
involving Russia and I don't know why
because I kind of generally lack
confidence injustice being carried out
and the real truth being found I'm kind
of cautiously optimistic that special
prosecutor Robert Muller is eventually
going to figure all of this stuff out I
I'm normally such a cynic and a skeptic
and sort of the opposite of naively
thinking it's all going to be worked out
the way the law dictates but for some
reason I am holding out hope that Robert
Moeller is actually going to get to the
bottom of this and it is national
tragedy after bungled disaster combined
with terrible leadership and corrupt
lies days at day after day we want to
believe and maybe this is what I'm
experiencing experiencing I want to
believe that someday we will actually
figure out what happened it will sort of
get straightened out and then I don't
know we'll get back on our back on the
horse so to speak maybe I am naive and
if I am I don't know send me emails
ideally not too angry the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad